はいでは皆さんこんにちは
私のプレゼンを始める前にですね2つ見てもらいたいグラフっていうのがあります
まず1つ目将来に希望が持てるかということに対するグラフです
見ていただくとですね日本が一番希望が自らない国であるということがわかると思い
ます
もう一つ見てもらいたいグラフがあります
努力すれば報われるかということに対する回答のグラフです
見てもらうと同じく日本の数字が低いということがわかるかと思います
努力しても報われないと思っていてですね人間頑張ることというのはできるものなの
でしょうか
人生をですね明るく照らしてくれるものっていうものをそれが何かというのを考えた時
に僕はそれは希望だというふうに思います
希望とは将来に対する明るい見通しのことをいいます
昨日よりも今日今日よりも明日毎日がもっと良くなるんじゃないかそういうふうな
明るい見通しを持って生きていられる
それほど素晴らしいとにず歳の取り方というのはないんじゃないかなっていうふうに僕
は思います
どうやったら自分の将来に明るい見通しを持つことができるんだろうか
誰が自分の将来に明るい見通しをくれるんだろうか
僕は思いますそれはあなた自身が最も自分の人生を明るく照らすことができると僕は
信じています
いうわけで今日の私のプレゼンのテーマは
イルミネート位はハートは良いはセルフ
自分自身で自分の心を照らすにはというプレゼンを今から始めたいと思います
よろしくお願い致します
ありがとうございます
今日お話しするのは全部で3つのことをお話しします
僕たちが誰に対して希望ともしていいのかそしてどうやってそれを灯しているのか
そしてともされた彼ら自身がどうやって希望灯し続けているのかその3つのことをお
話ししたいと思います
まず1つ目誰に対して僕たちはともしているか
僕たちは小学生から若手社会人までを対象とした
教えない教育というものを行っています僕らが教えないというポリシーを掲げているの
はそれは人間誰であろうと自分自身の足であることができるそう信じているからです
小学生と大学生あまりに対照が違うんじゃないかそういう風に思われるかもしれません
が大切なところは一緒だという風に僕たちは考えています
そのためのスタート地点はああなりたいという存在を一緒に組み込むことです
まずは小学生の事例からお話をしたいと思います
僕たちはマーブルタウンという事業を行っています
この写真はですね子供たちが館1時間前から並んでいる写真です
今の世の中こんなにですねわらわらと子どもたちが並ぶようなものってあるかっていう
となかなか少ないんじゃないかなというふうに思います
じゃマーブルタウンって何だのっていうことでもう少し話を説明させていただきます
まあフルタウンとは子どもたちが街をつくる事業で2日間が4日間をかけて子どもたち
が街を作っていきます
子どもたちはまず住民登録をし低コストハローワークから仕事をもらっていきます
警察官だったりアナウンサーだったり銀行だったりそういうところで職業体験をすると
10分間で10マーブル
という給与が支払われますそしてなんとですね10%が税金として徴収されるという
仕組みになっているんです
この10%を徴収された製品はどうなるかというとですね
この後に町で行われる選挙の町長が自分たちで新しい公共事業を使うというふうに使わ
れます中には自分の方で商品を開発して起業する子もいますそれがすごい簡単ではあり
ますが僕たちが行っているマーブルターンという授業になります
ああああああ
our なりたいという存在がいるとですねどういうふうに子どもたちが力を発揮する
かということを少しお見せしたいと思います
こちらよく見ていただくとですね何かのゲームのキャラだったりどっかのゲームの
キャラみたいな方があると思うんですけどこれ子どもたちが自分で作ってきたものなん
です
それからこれこれも子どもが自分で作ってきたものなんです
それからちょっとこの写真だとわかりにくいと思うんですけど見ていただきたいな左下
の方ですねちょっと拡大します
これ何かというとですねガチャガチャです
この
赤い四角赤い丸で囲んだところ見ていただくと分かるんですけどペットボトルがあって
それを回すとですね中からガチャガチャが出てくるんです
それから中には自分でですね映画館を開業した子供もいます
この子はですね自分で動画を撮ってきて動画編集してですね
光が入らない空間をつくって映画館をつくったんです
僕たちはこの子供たちに対してどういうふうに作ればいいかということは教えていませ
ん
彼ら自身がああーーなりたいと思った時に動き出したということなんです
彼らがまあこのような商品を開発するのには1ヶ月くらいの期間がかかります
じゃあマーブルタウンの中でああなりたいと思える存在というのはどういう存在なのか
というとですね
それはもう何度も僕達のこのマーブルタウンに来てくれて
マーブルを稼ぐですねもさになった高学年の小学生です
低学年の子たちはそういう高学年の小学生たちをみて自分もああいうふうになりたいな
そう思って動き出すんです
いやいやお店屋さんごっこしたいだけじゃないのかと言われるとそんなことはありませ
ん
なかなかタウンですね政治に興味を持っている小学生って少ないんじゃないかなって
いうふうに思うんですけれども
マーブルたーーーーの中での事例を一つお話しします右下にいる王冠をかぶった子が
この町の町長さんです
彼は
自分自身でですねええ
国家を作詞作曲してきたりとか
この街がどうあるべきなのかっていうですねサミット一人で仕切ったんですね
そしたらどうなったかっていうとこうなったんです
今まで140人だいたいくる中で2人しかいなかった
国王の立候補する子がですね7人にまで増えたんです
僕の小学校602いたんですけど生徒会長に換算し水戸ですね28に立候補するって
いうのは凄まじい町がこの街で起きているということですねそれがああなりたいという
存在の大切さです
小学生だけではありません実際に大学生における事例も説明します
僕たちは半年間の長期実践型インターンシップというものを行っています
インターンシップとは企業の中で就業体験をするものになりまして普通はいつかかんと
か
生が来て2週間くらいのものなんですけれども僕たちはこういう特長を持っています
ひとつ目経営者と一緒に新規事業を実際に立ち上げるという経験を
いるということ
2つで大学の期間中は週に3日
夏休みとかであれば週に5日間企業の元に行きます
そして半年間という期間はですね国内でも最長クラスのインターンシップになります
なぜ彼らはこのような過酷な道に踏み出してしまったんだろうか
それは2つのああなりたいという存在です
一つ目は実際にですね半年間インターンシップをすることで大きく成長した経験者を
充てです
もう一つそれは夢追う経営者との出会いによってです
ああなりたいという存在がいれば小学生でやろうと
大学生であろうと大人でやろうとすべてはここから始まるんだと僕は思っています
ではああなりたいという存在がいたときにどうやって近づいていけばいいんだろうか
僕たちはそこでキャンパスというものを用意しています
それは失敗と挑戦が繰り返せる空間を用意しています
先ほどマーブルタウンで言えば3つ気をつけていることがあります
大人の協力を教えない事っていうのを意識していますそれから保護者を進入禁止にする
ことです
3つ目はまだ振るという技術科を用意することです方五社という起こる存在がいない
失敗しても大丈夫そういう空間をつくることで
た
ミントマーブルタウンの起業率は40%です
たぶん日本で一番高い企業率を誇る街なんじゃないかなというふうに思います
じゃあ一方でまた大学生の事例で話なもう一個すいません失礼しましたもう一個僕らの
キャンパスには用意している大切なものがあります
それは通知表を用意しています
マーブルターン終わったあと僕らのもとにはこういう声が届いていきます
商品が売れたということだったりあとはこの稼いだマーブルを何回もですね数えなく
なってしまうというそういう子どもたちがいるんですよねあとはもう次回に向けていつ
かわかんないんだけれどももうすでに商品開発している
そういうのは声が届くんですこれはですねああ
あのなぜ彼らがそういうふうにそこまで興奮してしまうかそれは他者が認めてくれた
にも知らない他者が認めてくれたということが嬉しいです
でもう一つ大学生においても僕らが容易シールキャンパスというものを紹介します
事業というものを経営者の下で行うそういうなインターンシップをしているわけなん
ですけれども
新規事業だから会社の中で誰もですねノウハウを持ってないんです失敗しても不思議
じゃないんです
だから思い切ったチャレンジができるんです
そしてもう一個通知表は社会人と同じもの
評価基準として用いてます
確かに過酷かも知れませんだからこそでも自分の自信につながるんです
もう少し具体的にインターンシップの事例を一つ紹介したいと思います
補聴器屋さんでインターンシップをした事例になります彼女は楽天で始めてですね
補聴器業界のネットショップというものを作りました
売り上げはですね半年間で約270万円ぐらいのものをゼロから作り出しました
その結果どうなったかというとですね実は今楽天にはですね複数の企業の参入が相次い
でいるという状態が起きているんです
この真似できる成功というはですね希望となって他者を照らすことができるっていう
ことなんですね
それくらいかなり難しいチャレンジではありました
僕たちはアハなりたいという存在を用意することそれから挑戦と失敗ができる空間を
用意すること
それが僕らの教えない教育の最初のスタート地点になります
では最後にですねどうやってそのと思った希望というものが彼ら自身の手で灯し続けて
いくのかということを残りの時間でお話ししていきます
そのための大切なキーワードはこの試行錯誤というキーワードになります
試行錯誤とはやってみたいことが複数ある状態です
マーブルタウンの中では真似したいようなて本というのはたくさんいます
彼らはそういうのを見てですね商品8お店を出す場所を変えたりだとか陳列を変えたり
だとか
声の大きさ変えたりだとか中にはですね商品の値段を上げたことでですね商品の売れる
戸数増えた子っていうのもいたんです
そういうような形で彼らは失敗を失敗と思わずにチャレンジを続けていくということを
しています
大学生に対してはどうか僕らも同様にその道の成功者というものを用意しています
先ほどの姉とショップであれば楽天で実際に位置取った人に意見を聞きに行ける環境と
いうのは僕ら用意しています人間と人間と交流なので実際にどういう行動が教えて
もらえて何なのかというのは分からないんですよね
ですがそれによって成果がいたとき彼らはこういうふうに言います
今回チャレンジしたから初めてこの成果が生まれたんだと
それが彼らの次の挑戦の原動力につながっていくんです
実際ですねそんなにうまくいくもんなのかということでいうとまあ中あれば1個ぐらい
だと思います
ですが彼らは実際僕が見ていて思うのはそう簡単に絶望しません
それはですね選択肢があるからなんです1個目はダメだったけど2つ目3つ目っていう
ところでやればどこかでうまくいくんじゃないかそう思ってる間というのは人間
なかなか絶望しないものなんです
そういうふうにいろんな数を試していく中で彼らは少しずつ少しずつ
ちょっとした成果を手に入れ始めます
そうするとですね徐々に実は後ろに始めます
今回自分がうまくいったのは何でだったんだろうあの時失敗したのは何でだったん
だろうっていうことに自分たちの行動を見始めるんです
今までは人の真似をしていただけそれが徐々に自分の方に心の関心が向いてくるんです
ね
自分の思考の質問の仕方が悪かったのかなぁ
いやいやマネの仕方が悪かったのかな
徐々に彼らは気づき始めますうまくいくかどうかというのは自分次第であるということ
に気づき始めます
そうするとですねこういうサイクルが回るようになり始めます
試してみるでうまくいったか失敗したが振り返る
で
もっと上手くいくようにするために改善をする改善したらやっぱ試してみたくなる
このサイクルが徐々に徐々に舞い始めます
自分で自分をよくするというサイクルが回り始めるんです
そうすると昨日よりも今日今日よりましたもっと自分はよくなれるじゃないか
そういう希望がやがて彼ら自身の中に灯り始めるんです
そんなに世の中ですねうまくいくが来るはしませんよって話なんですけども
そういう時に僕らが言ってる事っていうのがありますそれはこれです
先ほども出てきましたけどコンフォートゾーンというも場所を翔び出せということを
言っています
コンフォートゾーンとは快適な空間のことをいいます
見ず知らずの人のところにいるよりも知ってる人たちと一緒にいた方が快適です
サッカーでもあの阿部で戦うよりホームで戦う方は快適です
そういう快適な空間を翔び出せということを言っています
最初は確かにコンフォートゾーン飛びれると非常に深いです
よくあるのがですねインターンシップの一番最初と会社の電話番をするとかですね
警護間違えたりだとか対応遅くて怒られたとかそういうことがあったりするんですけど
数十回ぐらい繰り返すと徐々にその空間にいることに慣れてくるんですね
確かに電話ファンに出たというのはすごく小さな世界成果かもしれませんが毎日こう
いうチャレンジを繰り返すということを僕らは大切にしています
数十回繰り返したとしてもまだ怖いとか不快だって思うのであればそれはコンフォート
ゾーンを一気に外に飛び出しすぎなんです僕たち大人の役目はほどよい大きさが
チャレンジの場所を用意
するということを意識しています
という風に小さな成果を毎日その狩りたくさん積み重ねていくということを僕らは意識
しています
人前でプレゼンをしたければまずは一人でいいから一人の人に対してうまく話せるよう
になろう
5人の人10人の人というふうに徐々にそういう怪談をうまく設けていくっていうこと
を僕らは意識しています
それであってもまだ成果出ないということもありますですが人前で話すことができ
なかった
そうであったとしてもそういうふうに自分が苦手を克服し続けたということはですね
彼らの次のチャレンジの大きな勇気になっていきます
そうは言ってもまだ辛いこともあるのかも知れませんそういうときにやっぱり大切なの
は一緒に頑張る仲間だというふうに僕は思っています
やっぱりインターンシップをやっているとまぁお互いに悩みは木てたりするんですね
そう言うとなると彼ら自身は互いに互いを励まし合います
そうする中で徐々に互いが互いを照らし合うそういう状態が生まれてくるんです
いつのまにか減らされるはずの存在であった彼らが日毎モスが合えと少しずつ少しずつ
変わっていくんです
ここで皆さんに一度少し考えていただきたいなと思うことがあります
社会に出ることの不安の正体とは一体何なのかということです
わかりやすく言えば就活ってことですね
それはですねこの日5 tomos 時に誰かに何かを与えられるがは仮想化という話
だと思うんです
大学までというのは知識を与えられ服を与えられ
お小遣いを与えられというふうに与えられる生活をしているんです
ですが
この就活でですね面接に行った瞬間にこう聞かれるんです
あなたは何が貢献できるんですかあなたは何も僕にくれるんですか
という風に面接官は言うんですこの雪丁寧に教えたり与えたりとかすればするほどこの
与える側から与えられる側に転換できないんです
これが就活の一番
の大きな問題だと僕は思っています
僕は思います自分自身を照らすことができる人というのは誰かを照らすことができる人
であるというふうに僕は思います
そして僕は信じていますああなりたいという存在とコラボして挑戦と失敗を繰り返し
コンフォートゾーンを飛び出し続ける苦しい時には一緒に仲間がいればいい
そうすれば誰であろうと自分自身の心を照らすことができると僕は信じています以上で
僕のプレゼン終わりたいと思いますご静聴ありがとうございました